now the small salt Mining City of Bak
moot in eastern Ukraine is the latest
focus of the war with Russian advances
being held back for the moment but the
situation is increasingly severe after
months of bombardment with reports of a
possible Ukrainian withdrawal as it
could soon be encircled
well we're joined now by the former
Chief of the general staff the former
head of the British army General Lord
Richard dannett always a pleasure to
have you on the program thank you for
coming on on a Sunday we're talking
about back moot what's your
understanding about the latest of that
situation
well it would seem to me that the
ukrainians are coming to the very
sensible tactical decision that to
withdraw rather than run the risk of
being completely encircled
um now makes sense frankly Blackwood has
been the focus of fierce fighting since
last Autumn uh it's worth remembering
that um it was the Wagner group under
prison that um really wanted to try and
show to the Russian army that they could
achieve a victory whether it which the
Russian army couldn't well this is
dragged on now for a better part of six
months with huge loss of life on the
Russian side so from the Ukrainian
perspective you could say that with
bakmud pretty much smashed the pieces
now as a town as a city there's nothing
really worth defending
um strategically it's not very
significant but it's achieved its aim of
effectively being the Anvil on which so
many Russian lives have been broken and
therefore it makes complete sense for
the ukrainians now to withdraw to a more
defensible line uh and continue the
battle there because the really key
thing the overall thing is that
ukrainians need to hold the Russians
while the Russians Mount their current
offensives and I don't think we've
really seen the real meat of that yet so
that at some point in the late spring
early summer the ukrainians can allow to
mount a really strong counter-offensive
utilizing the modern equipment that
we're now giving them
that's really interesting actually about
how you explain the kind of spread of
the war and the kind of strategy going
on I mean there's been a lot of talk
about a rough Russian spring offensive
how would you say that is going
well I don't think we've really seen it
start yet
um if they are serious about launching a
new offensive then I'm sure they are
because they've got to try and move the
war along in some positive direction
from the kremlin's point of view and
they've recruited and brought in maybe a
couple of hundred thousand maybe a
million three hundred thousand
additional into their army and of course
but remember these will be very poorly
trained we know they've been pretty
poorly equipped and they're very poorly
LED it's going to lead to significant
loss of life on the Russian side many
Russian families I've got to find that
their husbands Sons or other young
people have been taken away from them as
the ukrainians sit on the Strategic
Defense for a while and allow the
Russians to throw themselves into the
teeth of of their far apart it's when
that has reached its Climax and the as
we would say the Russians have
culminated in their offensive which I
don't think will be for a little while
yet that's the moment that the
ukrainians must turn the table on them
and use the uh up with two tanks to
challenge the tanks we've given them the
island infantry fighting Vehicles the
self-propelled artillery and the like to
mount a really decisive potentially
decisive counter-offensive and I think
that I'm not alone in believing that a
few decisive Blues struck at certain
points along that very extended front on
the Russian army could well have the
effect of breaking the morale of the
Russian soldier and breaking the back of
the Russian army the thing is you don't
have to defeat an Army in detail
everywhere on the battlefield you've
just got to convince enough of its
soldiers that they've lost and when they
think they've lost they have lost
that's so interesting and it and for you
talking about you know the loss of life
on the Russian side as well and how
that's going to trickle back of course
because all of these men are going to
have families as well in Russia and
that's going to impact things as well
obviously
um you're talking about these decisive
moments uh coming up when Ukraine can
use the weapons and the Firepower that
it's been given do you think the West
has done enough in getting the equipment
that Ukraine needs to the front line
to be frank I don't think we've done
enough
um we need to do as much as we possibly
can to ensure that this war is concluded
this year and
well the debate has agonized for quite
some time when eventually the Germans I
think rather encouraged by us decided to
give leopard two tanks a number of other
countries have followed that the
American Abraham's tanks won't be
available for quite some time and
frankly fighter jets won't be available
for quite some time so this
counter-offensive by the ukrainians is
going to have to go with what they've
got bear in mind they've got a lot of
their own equipment still they've got a
lot of Russian equipment that they've
captured which clever Ukrainian
mechanics will have refurbished and made
available so that showing their
characteristic determination their much
better operational planning they're much
better Battlefield leadership and
discipline I think there's every
prospect that the ukrainians can mount a
successful counter-offensive probably as
I said late spring early summer and um
provided that's planned properly and
seen through and we continue to give
them as much equipment and ammunition as
they need then there is a chance of
having some decisive outcome on the
battlefield this year none of us want to
be here Sophie this time next year
discussing a war that's in the Deep
Freeze and dragging on in a first world
war traditional type nature
yeah absolutely right on that um you're
talking about the need or the desire to
try it and conclude the wall this year
but what does an end game look like
because you know frankly you know I
can't imagine Putin just being like okay
right this is all a terrible mistake I'm
just going to get the guys out that's it
let's pretend it never happened
well I'd like to think that if the cams
are offensive by the ukrainians is
sufficiently well planned supported and
executed that Putin won't be in a
position to do too much decision making
himself that if his army crumbles and
runs then I think there's quite likely
that he'll be swept out of the Kremlin
as well and you'll also have to then ask
the question which everybody does is
well if it's not going to be Putin in
the Kremlin who is it going to be well
to be honest I don't really know the
answer to that question but what I would
say is I think the group of people the
group of leaders who are most
disaffected in Russia at the present
moment are the senior generals they've
seen Putin totally interfere with a war
they probably don't largely agree with
they realize that their Weaponry is
distinctly inferior to that of the West
and that's largely through the
corruption in the Russian defense
procurement process so I could see
General garazimov the chief of the
general staff who's now been put in
charge in overall command uh in in
Ukraine itself to be the one if you make
a sufficiently sensible plan and have
the moral courage to see it through it
could be the generals that topple the
top of the Putin and push him out of the
Kremlin
um there's going to be a lot of change
in Russia over the next 12 months so
I've got no doubt that's fascinating and
actually one of the few times that you
can hear someone actually
arguing away forward
um that you can actually imagine
happening so well as you say there's
going to be a lot of changes to come
we're gonna have to see how that unfolds
I just want to talk a little bit about
the UK defense if I may as well are you
concerned that sending so much
ammunition tanks obviously there's talk
about Japs in the future as well whether
that could put the UK's defense
capability at risk
well I mean also by definition it does
but then you have to ask the next
question which does it matter
um who do we think we might have to be
fighting this year next year whatever
um the answer is difficult to tell
um it could well be Russia but the war
with Russia is currently going on and
Ukraine is fighting it so it makes
complete sense that we support Ukraine
to the maximum but the really important
thing or the additional important thing
is that we are firing up British
industry to make sure that we're placing
orders to replace our stock of m-law
anti-tank weapons all ranges of
ammunition and ask ourselves bigger
questions about our land Warfare
capability do we have plans for enough
main battle tanks in our Armory do we
have sensible plans for the next
generation of infantry fighting vehicles
and I think many of us would actually
think that our plans are not sufficient
and that the refresh of the integrated
review which is used to be published
this week and then the budget next week
frankly I and others hope that we will
see an increase in defense spending and
a significant proportion of that will go
on replenishing our land Warfare stocks
and improving our overall land Warfare
capability
yeah it's interesting there's lots of
talk isn't there about what will happen
with the defense budget Sunday Times
reporting today which is soon I can set
to announce a multi-billion pound uplift
to the defense budget during potentially
a trip to the US and Ben Wallace
reportedly wants 11 billion pounds over
two years I mean that's not going to
happen is that
I don't see why I shouldn't it's um it's
a lot of money but it's actually in the
totality of everything it's not a vast
and impossible amount of money yes of
course it's got to come from somewhere
and there are a lot of other demands on
the government's finances for money
elsewhere but at the end of the day and
the security of the Nations the safety
of our citizens is the number one
responsibility of government and defense
although some can argue it's fairly well
funded the balance within defense is not
right there is a deficiency in our land
Warfare fighting capability okay you can
say so if he he would say that wouldn't
he because he used to be in charge of
the army but it's a fact that most
independent observers would agree with
so the Army has been the poor cousin in
terms of investment over the last 10 15
years and frankly if we want to have a
credible Army that's got to change
okay thank you very much it's always
really interesting to get your
perspective thank you thanks Sophie